vous êtes qui regardez dans le
rétroviseur on comprendrait côté arrêté
la voiture
quelqu'un va apparaître dans quelques
secondes
jacques est remonté très bien fait
savez-vous s'est pas seulement dans les
couloirs si ce n'est pas un enlèvement
je vois pas ce que ça non plus c'est
stable
oui c'est stable bien celle qui fait
quelque chose pour nous ramener jack
c'est franck franck le chauffeur est
pourquoi tu lui parles encore diack a
été infecté par un virus mortel
ça veut dire que mon fils tu vas mourir
il faut que je mette pour mettre ce que
vous ne pouvez pas tenir j'en fais pas
c'est une de mes règles
maintenant une seconde ça sort à peine
du pressing
la médicale c'est psychologique hier
franck je suis là
vraiment jouer les super-héros tu sais
volée
anthony ces mois sortait de la maison
allons mettre les madeleines au four le
seraient les maliennes